la publication de cette étude avait eu
un impact considérable le rétropédalage
auquel on assiste désormais pourrait lui
aussi être lourd de conséquences pour
bien comprendre revenons d'abord sur le
contenu de cette étude aujourd'hui
désavoué paru le 22 mai est basée sur
l'analyse des données de milliers de
patients à travers le monde les
résultats affichés dans la revue
britannique
dylan 7 attestent de l'inefficacité
voire même de la dangerosité de
l'hydroxyde rockin dans le traitement
contre le kobe de 19 voilà qu'ils
devaient mettre un terme au débat qui
déchire la communauté scientifique
depuis des semaines c'est en tout cas en
se basant sur les résultats de cette
étude que l' oms avait décidé de
suspendre les essais cliniques avec
l'hydro xi chloroquine en france le
ministre de la santé s'était saisi lui
aussi très rapidement des conclusions
pour annoncer sa décision suite à la
publication dans zealand 7 d'une étude
alertant sur l'inefficacité et les
risques de certains traitements du coc
vite 10,9 dont l'idh roxy chloroquine
j'ai saisi le haut conseil de la santé
publique pour qu'ils analysent et me
propose sous 48 heures une révision des
règles dérogatoires de prescription ce à
quoi le haut conseil de la santé
publique avait répondu en recommandant
de ne pas utiliser l'hydroxyde
chloroquine dans le traitement contre le
commis de 19
alors qu'on pouvait penser le débat clos
coup de théâtre ce mardi avec la
publication de ce communiqué sur le site
de zilon 7
nous publions une expression
d'inquiétude pour alerter les lecteurs
sur le fait que de sérieuses questions
scientifiques ont été portés à notre
attention nous mettrons cet avis à jour
dès que nous aurons de plus amples
informations
une mise en garde qui fait suite à de
nombreuses interrogations qu'avait
soulevées l'étude du 22 mai questions
autour des données qui ont été récoltés
est question aussi autour de l'intégrité
voire de l' expertise de la société
surgissent fer qui a traité les
informations médicales en question après
la parution plusieurs voix s'étaient
élevées au sein de la communauté
scientifique notamment celle du
professeur didier raoult tu joues si
vous ai passé quatre mille malades dans
les mains croyez pas que je vais changer
parce qu'il ya des gens qui font du big
data qui est une espèce de fantaisie
complètement délirante qui prend des
données dont on connaît pas la qualité
qui mélange tout comment voulez-vous que
une étude foireuse fait avec les big
data change ce que nous avons vu si ce
rétropédalage du land cette donne raison
à ceux qui critiquent l étude
il n'indique pas pour autant que
l'hydroxyde chloroquine est efficace
contre le coc vie de 19 en revanche il
se pourrait bien que la revue médicale
soit contrainte de se rétracter
concernant cette étude
alors ce revirement est il en mesure de
modifier le choix du ministre de la
santé
réponse de la porte parole du
gouvernement le ministre de la santé a
écrit en fin de semaine dernière à la
rédaction du lens est pour lui demander
une relecture des données brutes telles
qu'elles avaient été livrées dans le
cadre de l'étude que vous citez je
voudrais également souligner que les
autorités sanitaires en france ou à
l'international se sont fondés sur
différentes études pour prescrire le
fait qu'il devait y avoir une suspension
des essais cliniques sur l'idh roxy
chloroquine donc ce n'est pas sur le
seul fondement de l'étude du lent le
fait que cette décision a été prise mais
de son côté l' oms a annoncé ce mercredi
la reprise des essais cliniques sur
l'hydroxyde chloroquine une preuve que
si elle n'était pas l'unique source
cette étude yolande sept avaient eu un
rôle prépondérant dans l'utilisation de
led anti chloroquine